Jimmy you must be going [ __ ] mental  oh I I guess you guys can't see me I  don't know why I'm actually a piece of  bread I might not hear this one now that  she's here I'm gonna bring it up again  Beth started in with me last night she's  upset with me you gotta explain this  that if I get the coronavirus you feel  I'm gonna give up and get my hat I feel  like I'm dying if and when we get this  you have to remain positive  you have to just remain positive no  you're not are you crying  I just want to make a statement and I'm  making this in front of Jimmy and Jimmy  knows when I'm lying the best part of my  life is being with you I'm not gonna die  and leave you to some [ __ ] [ __ ] to  marry yoke and like the coronavirus I  want to be here with you yes I'm gonna  complain during it and I'm gonna I'm  gonna isolate myself in the bedroom I  will bring you bring me my meals the  door slide them under the door and I'll  take tylenol and all that I wish he gave  up  you